a major Republican donor in Florida is
threatening to cut off funding to
politicians who oppose a ban on assault
weapons al Hoffman jr. has raised
hundreds of millions of dollars for
Republicans but in the wake of the
shooting at Stoneman Douglas High School
Hoffman sent an email to other GOP
donors urging them to support a ban on
assault weapons
Jericka Duncan sat down with Hoffman at
his Florida home she's in parkland
Jericka good morning good morning the
longtime GOP fundraiser and wealthy real
estate developer said he literally
helped build this community but after
last week's deadly shooting he now says
that his influence and dollars will be
determined by one major issue when you
first heard about that shooting at a
school another school shooting what was
your initial reaction I was incredulous
I couldn't believe it I thought I had my
heart in my hands that feeling led 83
year old Republican donor al Hoffman jr.
to stop contributing to his own party's
candidates unless they support a change
in the gun laws I will not write a check
for anyone who does not propose a ban on
assault weapons you were quoted as
saying this particular shooting was the
end of the road for you that's right why
not a Sandy Hook well I've been after so
many politicians to adopt legislation
and always the answer is that well we're
working on it we're working on and
nothing ever changes the original
federal assault weapons ban was passed
in September of 1994 but expired after
ten years between May 2003 and June 2008
there were at least 17 attempts to renew
or replace the ban but none made it to a
vote and an effort to pass a permanent
ban after the 2012 Sandy Hook massacre
failed to get Senate approval last
Friday Hoffman wrote an email to half
dozen GOP donors asking them to follow
his lead would you be willing to write a
check to Democrats and Republicans who
are in favor of the ban I would support
a fiscally conservative person who
supports the ban and at this moment in
time I really don't care whether it's a
republic
Democrat do you really believe something
will change as a result of the parkland
shooting don't know I hope so
where's just a start right now but I
think we need to build the movement and
time and the Lord willing we'll be will
accomplish some things Hoffman also said
that he sent an email to Florida
Governor Rick Scott who's considering a
Senate run we reached out to Scott for
comment and have not heard back yet gale
all right there we go we all hope
something will change thank you very
much